you know i shout out to russ i think
russ has done a good job of like trying
to educate people i [ __ ] with heavy no
russ is dope um
and
he'd be he'd be really giving like
honestly people really should just
listen like russ is not lying to y'all
right like he's not saying you might not
like the messenger and by the way russia
to me is fire as [ __ ] but you might you
know i understand
oh yeah it was amazing that chomsky was
amazing but but he's telling everyone
the truth
you know he's like what he's saying is
like yo if drake or kendrick or one of
these guys decided to go and if drake
went independent it break it break the
record game yeah for sure because it
would like fully pull the mask off
and so i think that's what stop about
what you guys are doing because you guys
easily could have signed with anyone
like i know this you know so like
you know uh to to to do the red bull
approach is like
it's funny too because i don't think
everybody was like
like you know people are trying to throw
like a little jab
dude when me and head saw that [ __ ] we
were like
wow
and you know i just think it was a warm
brew that was on red bull yeah um and
they had another
i just was like i just never seen it
work because i'm not hip to i'm not hip
to the rock groups you're talking about
i just know that i've seen rappers sign
a red bull yeah like i've seen it like
you know i mean bro really to be a
thousand what you like shout out to
rebel for sure like also there's a
difference in the pride pro product no
disrespect to warren brew but you guys
are like generational talents like
you can
whoever you run across a red bull ever
like you can ask them just a fact check
it like
the first meeting we ever had with red
bull we was like we want to own all the
ancillary income all the masters we're
not doing the publishing deal with you
and we're only doing the one off for a
short license
and they was like what
and then we came back to the second
meeting with like a manila envelope with
all the numbers and [ __ ] from distrokid
and all the products and then we broke
down the whole staff for the flow chart
and it was like oh [ __ ] like y'all
really operate as a real company and i
think that's the biggest biggest
difference the fact that we were able to
show
and actually communicate what our
business vision was how we seen the
whole year going and then have the music
attached to it on top of that and
nobody's going into those meetings that
way well not most people aren't no i
would say like ninety-five
most of the time it's like you know you
go to a meeting they get a little spill
i do this i do this and it's like so
this song this song
yeah yeah so majority of the time it's
just me and blast going into these
meetings because our attorney in new
jersey so it's like me and him walking
in i'm damned they're wearing basketball
shoes to these meetings and blasts in a
damn dicky suit or something like that
and they talking to us like we just the
natural rapper and then once we get to
actually have a conversation and tell
them like what we want and the
breakdowns and all this type of [ __ ]
like everybody jaw just be dropped and
they'd be like ah
like
one of these labels
we went they literally stopped this mid
conversation was like bro this is above
my pay grade like we could just end this
meeting i can't even have conversations
about this type of [ __ ] that's so crazy
you guys do you know would you say you
pretty much had meetings with most of
the majors
i don't know a major we haven't met with
yeah we met with every major every
single one